I'm a pretty casual presenter so I'm
just gonna get started with saying thank
you all for coming out because I don't
know about all of you but 10:30 is
really early in the morning for me so
this was kind of a struggle so thank you
all for making it out here
hi my name is Joyce and I'll just start
with a very quick brief blurb about
myself but the focus is on why is some
of this context might make some of the
rest of the talk a little more
interesting so I got started a
machine-learning a couple years back I
worked on building a machine learning
library enclosure which is a functional
programming language as it turns out
functional programming a machine
learning have a lot of fun common ground
that make it really nice to do a lot of
data processing in closure and from
there I went from engineering and
machine learning sort of into the deep
end of machine learning research and
this meant working at deep mind for one
summer on reinforcement learning
research and then working at the
Stanford NLP group on some natural
language processing research around
language modeling and then going on in
doing some stuff in adversarial learning
this was all for the past year then I
sort of decided I went too deep in on
machine learning research didn't really
like it and moved on to go work at
sidewalk labs for a little bit and
they're another alphabet company that's
working on building cities and using
technology to help build cities better
but during the course of my time really
working on machine learning and machine
learning research one of the things that
really caught my mind was this emerging
conversation around AI bias right this
is something that when I first got
started out in machine learning this was
not on anyone's minds whatsoever in the
past couple years I don't know why this
keeps cutting out in the past couple of
years this has been a topic that's
really risen to the forefront of public
conversation around artificial
intelligence and also the academic and
researchers a conversation around the
impacts of their work in
I the title of this talk takes kind of a
snarky approach this write like how do
you fix AI
solutions to machine learning bias and
why they don't matter which I admit is a
little bit of a snarky intro to this
topic the majority of this talk will be
focusing on technical mitigations for
bias in data so essentially if we know
already that the data that's coming in
is screwed up is biased what are some of
the algorithms we can use to actually
combat this bias to account for this
bias and make predictions in context of
knowing what that bias might be or we
don't even know what that bias is but we
assume that there is some sort of
underlying bias there so most of this
talk is going to be technical but
honestly to me the most compelling part
of this is not the fact that there are
algorithms and in my case I'll
specifically be focusing on deep
learning algorithms it's not the fact
that there are these algorithms out
there and that we should be using it
it's that using these algorithms alone
isn't enough because they're sort of
tied into a much much bigger problem
here so I'm gonna get started with the
problem right we said how do we fix a AI
what is the problem so I want to take
you back in time a little bit in 1961 a
man named Clyde Ross tried to buy a
house in North Lawndale Chicago so Clyde
Ross was a black man he was born in the
Jim Crow South in Mississippi and his
father didn't know how to read or write
and the Mississippi authorities I was
fairly common back then sort of stepped
in and said hey you guys owe $3,000 in
taxes they couldn't pay it they also
didn't actually owe this in taxes but
because they couldn't pay it the
Mississippi authorities basically use
this as a way to seize back the land so
Clyde Ross's family lost his land they
defaulted back to sharecropping and he
himself went on to enlist in the army he
fought in World War two he moved to
Chicago in 1947 after World War two as
part of the great migration
when a lot of African Americans started
moving north and he worked in Chicago
for about 14 years had a stable wage had
a family and in 1961 he and his wife
tried to buy a home only to find that
the first home that they did buy was
this predatory contract where he wasn't
actually getting a legitimate mortgage
he wasn't actually owning the house the
house was falling apart and he was
responsible for all of the repairs of
this house but he was actually paying
back the real home own homeowner who
actually owned the house actually had
the equity and who could at any moment
that clyde ross missed any of his
payments kick clyde ross out bring in
another family equally desperate from
some sort of housing jack up the prices
and repeat the same deal all over again
and clyde ross had no idea that this is
what he was getting himself into right
so once he figured out that this was a
problem he was like okay I'm out of here
he tried to look around this
neighborhood and other neighborhoods
around him in Chicago for other homes to
buy and he found that he couldn't
because throughout the 1930s to 1960s
the federal government and as a result
of the federal government's practices
all of the private industry in real
estates adopted a practice of redlining
which essentially divided up cities and
divided up these urban realms into a
bunch of color-coded regions to indicate
how good this neighborhood is right so
if you were to give a mortgage to
someone in this home how likely is it
that they would be able to pay you back
but redlining from the 1930s the 1960s
very explicitly was targeted towards
preventing communities of color and
particularly black people at this time
from getting any share of legitimate
housing brief pause is there any reason
that it keeps cutting out to a blue
screen I'm gonna go on and you guys can
use that as a way to stay in focus with
the presentation so 1930s through 1960s
red
the interesting thing is if you go deep
enough into the story or in my case if
you just go deep enough into the podcast
about these stories you will find that
the actual words that the government has
set out to give guidelines for people on
how to actually color code these
neighborhoods for red neighborhoods
which was which was the worst write read
was called hazardous read meant that you
could pretty much not get any sort of
legitimate mortgage financing if you
were trying to get a home in one of
these neighborhoods the actual words
they used were these neighborhoods are
characterized by quote an infiltration
of lower grade classes and racial
populations let me double check that
that's right infiltrations of lower
grade populations and racial groups
those were the exact words that were
being used so this was a tactic that was
used to essentially prevent communities
of color from being able to buy houses
and being able to accumulate wealth by
having this equity now that was 1960s
right 1960s clyde ross tried to buy this
house in 2018 a woman named rochelle for
oude also tried to buy a house this time
near the malcolm x-- park in West
Philadelphia one of these brick row
houses and what she found was that you
know she had a good background she went
to Northwestern she had a good credit
score and she was making over 60,000 a
year teaching computer programming
Rutgers University and she applied once
was denied told that she needed to get a
more permanent salary because this
computer programming course she was
teaching was on contract so she left and
she got a job managing a multi-million
dollar grant fund at the University of
Pennsylvania and she applied again and
was denied again and the cycle just went
on
so what really changed between 1961 and
2018 right
what firstly we had a law passed in 1968
the fair housing law was passed which
essentially said you know you cannot
discriminate
people based off of their race based off
of their sex based off of any sort of
identity in terms of buying a home
buying getting a mortgage seeking
housing assistance this law was put in
place to essentially prevent what was
happening to clyde ross but I'm more
interested in the processes that
actually changed so the law changed
saying you can't discriminate anymore
and in 1961 the way we made these sorts
of judgments is we got a bunch of
information about the people who are
applying for this mortgage loan right
and a human would use some sort of
decision guideline to make a judgment on
whether or not this person could get a
mortgage in 1961 as I said they had very
explicit language guiding them telling
them what characterizes a neighborhood
that you should lend to people in and
what characterizes a neighborhood where
you shouldn't lend to people these were
decisions made by humans probably by the
1990s 2000s computers came around and a
lot of this started being taken
advantage a lot of the decisions started
being made by computers right you
instead of a human checking checkboxes
it was a computer taking over some of
the decision making and now in 2018 as
many of you probably know and suspect a
vast majority of these algorithms use
some sort of machine learning process
behind them it's a lot of numbers coming
in it's some sort of algorithm that may
be vaguely resembles a neural net maybe
resemble something else but then that
algorithm makes the decision about
whether or not this person should get a
mortgage and where that leaves us is
that last year in 2018 the center of
Investigative Reporting called reveal
went around and looked at around 400
different metro areas in the United
States and they looked at a lot of these
loan applications controlling for the
income of the applicants controlling for
the zip code of where in the
neighborhood of where they were applying
for and controlling for some of the
other factors such as credit scores
and loan amounts what they found was
that in at least sixty one of these
metro areas people of color were
routinely more likely to be denied a
mortgage than their white counterparts
even when you controlled for all of
these different factors right and where
that leaves us is this back here when we
were looking at those map of redlining
this is a map of st. Louis ok I think
and I'm not entirely sure cuz I'm not
from st. Louis
I think we're somewhere here downtown
but downtown areas especially several
decades ago also tended to be where the
ghettos were and where a lot of the
black people are concentrated so know
what no one in these areas who get any
sort of legitimate home financing and
today the statistics aren't exactly a
lot more promising right so why did I
just spend eight minutes going over all
of this I think my point that I'm trying
to make is that this isn't just some
isolated incident of oh computers can't
detect black people's faces as well or
let's look at a token m-miss style data
set that contains some bias I really
believe we all need to come to an
understanding that algorithms are
already fundamental building blocks in
decision-making in every single industry
that moves money in the United States
machine learning algorithms are already
everywhere they're built into so many
systems that we don't realize they're
built into and using data that is biased
and have bias built into them so this is
not an isolated incident this is
something that is indicative of a much
bigger problem and the reason I started
with housing specifically as an example
is that about a month ago
when I was first looking into making a
presentation about this I learned that
there was a new leaked memo about what
the federal government's Housing and
Urban Development Department wanted to
do and they basically are proposing a
rule change to make it much harder to
showed disparate impact which is to say
even though your policies aren't
specifically oh don't lend to X group
the impact of your policies leaves X
group much worse off than Y group that's
disparate impact and specifically the
introduction of this new rule change
makes it almost impossible to challenge
any sort of decision that's made by an
automated algorithm ok so this is
probably a little bit blurry but
essentially what it says is as long as
the person giving out the mortgage or
the bank or the company giving out the
mortgage can show that the protected
attribute let's say race wasn't
explicitly used in the model as an input
to the decision and no direct proxy for
it was used as an input than your fine
or if you got your algorithm from a
third party and that third party had
vetted it properly then you're fine so
as long as the third and they provided
no guidelines whatsoever on what sort of
testing the third party has to do right
as long as you buy from a third party
and the third party guarantees you that
yes I did testing and it is not biased
we're not discriminating then you as the
mortgage company or as the bank get off
free that's what this rule says so that
was a problem the problem is that we
have these algorithms baked into
basically every segment of society and
they're based off of what we know now
today is very biased data and today I
want to talk about a few technical
mitigations for this so knowing that the
data is biased how can we build
algorithms that combat this bias
acknowledge this bias and make accurate
predictions in spite of this bias
without reaching disparate impact and
we're going to be talking about three
different methods this is where we get a
little more technical and in the machine
learning space I'm going to top be
focusing on deep learning specifically
and for all of these I will try to do a
sort of high-level conceptual overview
and go into a little bit of the math and
show a little bit of the code
I will not be focusing much on the code
because honestly I don't know how many
of you have worked with machine learning
before but coding is not the fun part of
machine learning coding is kind of the
worst parts of machine learning honestly
the most exciting part about these ideas
are the concepts behind them and how
just a little bit of math can make these
very very widely applicable and the nice
part about coding with machine learning
is that oftentimes people have built
very nice extensive libraries for you
that contain all of these functions so
all of the code we're going to be
looking at today are part of a few
different libraries that all send out
the link for and post the link for at
the end so the first strategy we're
going to look at is something called
adversarial de biasing and I don't want
to bore anyone but I also don't want to
leave anyone behind so can I get a show
of hands here on who feels relatively
comfortable with the concept of machine
learning and what it consists of okay
does anyone want to do a little bit of a
quick refresher okay a few hints I'll do
this really quickly so I think machine
learning and concept is really
straightforward you take a bunch of data
that comes in in this case you have a
neural network which has these nodes
corresponding to basically numbers that
get passed through different layers of
the neural Nets so you get a bunch of
data coming in and then you multiply all
of your numbers coming in with a bunch
of different weights you get more
numbers you multiply those numbers by
more weights and add them together you
get more numbers so forth and so forth
until magically this pipeline transforms
down at the very end to some sort of
number representative of your prediction
that you're making it that this is
supervised learning you have a correct
label you're trying to predict and the
computation in this graph gets you from
your input data to some sort of
probability and the way that's done the
way this magic actually happens is that
each time you do this sort of trial and
error of guessing you use the gradients
that are coming back so you calculate
what sort of error you get at the end
and you take the gradient of that
and you use that to update all of the
weights update all of the values that
you're multiplying the input data its
phone from so what you get is over time
iteratively your input data and your
predictions start getting closer and
closer to the ground truth in
adversarial learning you have something
similar except you have a second
component of your neural net so
typically when you have a machine
learning model you have some sort of
input embeddings right
maybe it's an image and then you map it
down to a bunch of pixels you have some
shared hidden layers or just single
hidden layers in this case and then you
want to predict some sort of output Y
and in this method of adversarial de
biasing essentially what you're trying
to say is that okay I want to make a
very accurate prediction but I don't
want to discriminate on a certain
protected attributes okay so this
attribute might be gender might be race
might be age might be income something
else and what you're saying is I can't
just remove this input from the model
because this single input feature is
oftentimes highly correlated with a lot
of other inputs and a lot of other
things in the data remember how do a
housing rule that got proposed said okay
as long as you're not using that single
factor or some direct proxy for it
you're okay
that usually doesn't work that way right
because usually you have things like
these protected attributes correlating
very heavily with a lot of other very
legitimate features that you still want
to use for your prediction so
adversarial de biasing essentially says
okay let's build a model to try to
predict both okay
from the inputs let's both try to
predict the label Y and we try to
predict this protected attribute and
what we're going to do is we're going to
use regular back propagation to sort of
update the model for the classifier but
we're going to send back the negative
gradient or a negative signal for every
time that we guess the protected
attribute right
so what this looks like is you have an
input X you have some form of
transformations and your first few
layers of the neural net that get you to
G of X and then you make a prediction
you have one head of your neural net
that takes that shared learned embedding
layer and then you make a prediction for
the classifier but at the same time you
have another adversary a in this case
making a prediction of the protected
attributes based off of the same input
learned input embedding and what this is
doing essentially is making the claim
that even if so if I am able to very
accurately predict the protected
attribute let's say it's gender if based
off of this input I can make accurate
predictions as a classifier but I can
also tell very easily what the gender of
this applicant is then that means that
I've sort of encoded important
information about gender within my
neural net right otherwise there's no
way I'd be able to make this prediction
at the very end by sending a negative
signal back we're sort of trying to say
okay on the other hand if we can't
predict this protected attribute if I
can make successful predictions of
whatever I'm actually trying to predict
but I can't predict the protected
attribute that means that I haven't
accidentally encoded information about
this protected attribute into the neural
net itself so I'm sort of using all of
the useful information I can without
encoding anything that would let me
predict a protected attribute about this
person so if we look at the
formalization here and we'll get just a
little bit more into the math the loss
function you end up trying to maximize
look something like this you have or in
this case minimize you want to minimize
the loss across the classifier which is
your first term right the F of G of X
and y but you also want to minimize the
loss from your adversary or maximize the
loss and minimize in this case the
negative identity of the
Schloss so if you look at that J sub
Landa let's say that that's the identity
function with a negative gradient okay
that's what the red is showing over here
so you want to minimize the first loss
and maximize the second loss and what
you do is you take the negative gradient
of that you take the negative value of
the negative gradient of that giving you
a positive value and you want to
minimize the whole thing overall so the
way you actually build this out in code
ends up looking something like this you
don't it's a little bit easier to
visualize it this way instead of looking
at it as two separate heads here so you
have X coming in and one set of
predictor weights getting you to
prediction Y and a loss coming from that
normal prediction then you have a set of
adversarial weights on the other head
that takes that the logits that you get
at the very end and makes a prediction
about the protected attributes and what
this looks like
this is some tensorflow code showing how
this is set up your self dot classifier
model can be any sort of neural net that
you build and you pass an information
about what the dimensions of your
features are and what the placeholder
for your features are and you calculate
a loss based off of a very standard loss
function which is cross-entropy
and you look at essentially how accurate
my predictions in this batch are then
from there if you're trying to add d
biasing to this model you take what
you've already made the prediction from
and you feed that into another set of
weights so you use those weights in the
adversary model which again can be any
arbitrary neural net that you build on
top of this input over here you make
predictions about your protected
attributes and then you use the same
loss function to calculate your loss
from the adversary and here we start
computing the gradients right the
interesting part here is if you are
taking a D biasing head as well if
you're adding this adversarial loss on
top we get a couple more interesting
lines we say
okay take the gradients of the adversary
we normalize it we do this weird line
over here TF dot reduce some that sort
of takes the dot product of the original
classifiers gradient and the adversaries
gradients multiplies them we subtract
that off and then we do something else
where we multiply that by another way
and subtract that off what what the hell
is going on here right so what you're
seeing here is this update expression on
top what we've already said is that we
want to modify the weights throughout
the overall network by updating
according to the predictors loss for the
regular classifier but also by
subtracting off the gradient from the
adversary right whatever information is
coming in from the adversary whatever
updates that it wants to make we want to
do the opposite of those updates in some
senses so that gets us the very first
term up here and the very last term up
here the first term is the classifiers
gradients the last term is us
subtracting off some weighted version of
the adversaries gradient the middle term
is what's actually really interesting
because you take this subtraction and
sometimes you look at it and you say
actually by subtracting off the update
that we're making to the adversary is
lost we might end up with a vector that
still somehow benefits the adversary in
some way we want to make sure that when
we do this sort of subtraction between
these two gradients we're definitely not
helping the adversary whatsoever so the
way you make sure that the update that
you're making is maximally useful to the
classifier without ever helping the
adversary is that you also subtract off
a projection of the adversaries loss or
sorry the projector the classifier
gradients loss on the adversaries loss
so whatever direction you'd be making to
make an update for the adversary you
project the gradient of the regular
classifier onto that direction and you
subtract that off because that is
everything that could potentially be
helping your adversary
you say the adversary wants to make a
step in this direction we want to
subtract that off and that's the third
line you see in the if statement right
here we're subtracting off that
projection to make sure that nothing
helps the adversary and then we subtract
off the actual gradients from the
adversary as well so in the end that
ends up looking something like this when
we've gone through all the steps and
we've applied all the gradients you run
a minimizer on it
you call this for the adversary and you
call the same thing for the classifier
and as you step through all of this in
tensorflow it will essentially every
step calculate your gradients normally
from the classifier and if you choose to
add in a separate head to do D biasing
for you it'll run through these steps to
subtract off the gradients in a way that
can keep your predictions as accurate as
possible while trying to ensure
maximally that you can't make a
prediction about that about the
protected attribute so that's sort of a
high level and then into the weeds
overview of what this would look like
and the nice thing about the approach of
adversarial D biasing is that you can
choose whether or not you add the
separate head right it's a very easy to
add module on top of existing models if
you don't want to rebuild your model
whatever it looks like it's very easy to
add a separate head to do this sort of
computation for you the thing that's not
so nice about adversarial D biasing is
that you have to specify ahead of time
what you're protected attributes are so
in the inputs coming in you need to know
what could potentially be biased and you
need to say I'm specifically protecting
against this form of bias which often
times isn't the case that you know how
to specify exactly what you're trying to
protect against right so another
technique is dynamic up sampling of data
which essentially says let's say that we
don't know anything about the type of
data coming in except that it might be
biased and what we want to do is we want
to make sure that the
model is seeing sort of equal numbers of
all sorts of inputs such that it can
make accurate predictions on inputs that
it otherwise hasn't seen enough examples
of and therefore discriminates against
or performs worse against because it
hasn't seen enough of this right so if
you imagine a facial detection system if
you up sample data of underrepresented
populations then the predictor itself is
a lot less likely to have less accurate
predictions on these underrepresented
populations so it's hard to specify
again because you don't know exactly
what you're protecting against which
inputs exactly you want to up sample so
this technique relies on something
called a variational auto encoder and
the variational autoencoders starts from
an auto encoder we're going to start at
the basics an auto encoder takes in a
representation of your input and tries
to find another usually more useful
representation of it in one way or
another in the latent space so you're
trying to find a latent representation Z
in this case one that's a lot smaller in
dimensionality than your inputs and you
sort of do this by passing your input
through an encoder to get this latent
representation and then you pass that
latent representation back through a
decoder and the goal is to get your
input out the other side so you want to
make sure you can reconstruct the input
so you have an end-to-end network or you
can encode into some useful
representation and then using that
useful representation deconstruct back
out the problem with a simple example
like this and with directly encoding and
decoding is that you can get
representations from very similar inputs
that are completely disconnected from
each other in the latent space right I
can have inputs that when I look at them
as pictures they look very similar but
in this case the latent representations
in the space we're projecting into and
mapping into they might be very separate
but the neural net has somehow figured
out a way
to make the math work what we want is
for input representing inputs that look
similar to have latent representations
that are actually numerically similar as
well and that's where the variational
auto-encoder comes in and what that does
is instead of directly finding a
representation for your inputs it finds
in a mean and a sigma for you to sample
from a normal distribution your actual
representation so what this does is it
ensures that things that you are
projecting into this latent space that
were similar from the start should get
you similar means and similar standard
deviations and from that cluster in the
latent space if you sample randomly you
should be able to get something back out
the other side that looks like your
original input all of this is just to
say that we want to find a way to
categorize our inputs based off of their
latent underlying features right in an
image with a lot of different pixels we
don't actually know and can't specify it
at those starts what makes one input
very similar to another input sometimes
but if we can find an effective latent
representation that captures the ways in
which inputs are similar or unsimilar
then we can use that latent
representation to say okay I have a lot
of data coming in and I have very little
data that's coming in from this
particular group because this space in
the whole latent space has very few
examples in it so the goal of all of
this is to without having to know what
sort of attributes you're protecting or
where the bias might come in to be able
to find the underlying things within the
model itself the underlying features in
the representation that could be
underrepresented and use those examples
to then up weight and use more of those
inputs corresponding to underrepresented
features in the latent space so the loss
function we're going to get a little bit
into the math but this isn't for the
most part that complex it looks a little
bit more scary than it actually
yes so in the model for the variational
auto encoder you sort of have two
different losses you have one loss for
how well the encoder does and one loss
for how well the decoder does so the
first loss in here is the reconstruction
loss which corresponds to the decoder
and this says okay we're trying to
maximize the probability of
reconstructing our data right we're
trying to find latent representations
that's when we have an input we can
maximize the probability of
reconstructing that same input and here
we say all right we take the
reconstruction loss as the probability
that we get that original input back
from the representation we found for it
and the second part of this law says we
want to make sure that the encoder is
doing a good job of actually keeping the
distribution for the latent
representation clustered together
tightly remember what we said at the
beginning that the problem with a simple
model like the one on the left is that
you can have latent representations from
very similar inputs being very
disconnected in a latent space and we're
saying the way we fight that is we try
to make sure that they're densely
clustered in these normal Gaussian
distributions right because now you're
sampling a mean you're sampling from a
mean and a standard deviation so here
the KL divergence regulate regularizer
is saying let's make sure that the
representations produced by the encoder
which is the function Q that those
values Z are sort of tightly clustered
in a normal Gaussian and in this case P
of Z at the end is this normal unit
Gaussian distribution so we're trying to
make sure it's as densely clustered as
possible now the D biasing model we're
now going to look at the blue screens
really annoying the model we're actually
going to look at it looks something like
this so you have your standard encoder
and your decoder
you have your standard encoder and your
decoder in taking the X producing some
values Z and then trying to reconstruct
the X this technique tries to
simultaneously predict Y or whatever
you're trying to predict at the same
time as producing those latent
representations so it's saying we're not
actually trying to just find latent
representations at the end of the day we
are trying to make accurate predictions
we want to predict something in this
case Z 0 and Z naught in this case is
what you can imagine why in the previous
example was this is your true label so
you simultaneously try to predict and
produce your true label from your
encoder while you're the encoders
generating some latent representation of
your M of your input so if you're
passing in an image you're producing a
latent representation of the image that
hopefully holds some salient information
and you're also making a prediction then
you revise all of this all of the
weights for this based off of that
reconstruction so you're trying to make
sure your encoding is as solid as
possible but it's based off of this
latent space that you can look what's
actually underrepresented in this latent
space and use those to update the
probabilities of Rhys electing a certain
data point in training so the loss
function for this will look very similar
right it doesn't actually look very
similar if you look at the way it's
written out but if you look at what each
of these means it's essentially adding a
classification loss on top of our
regular variational auto encoder loss
these second two terms correspond to
what we've already seen the second term
here is the reconstruction loss you're
taking whatever your input is from your
reconstructed input taking the
difference saying ah how badly am i
doing and then the second term is a
little more complex way of taking the
actual MU and the Sigma's that you've
sampled and saying okay do they produce
these densely clustered latent
representations I'm looking for and your
first term is a term we're almost
familiar with which is
this encoder is also making a prediction
about whatever I want to predict how
accurate is it being so the loss for
this big Network is the losses of all of
these others added together the
classification loss and the regular
encoding and decoding loss and the
actual interesting part of the model is
how you do the updating of positive D
biasing probabilities right so we don't
actually back propagate gradients when Y
is equal to zero because we only want to
look at the positive examples and what
we do is we sort of construct a
histogram of variables in the latent
space now that we're ensured by our
decoder that similar inputs are being
clustered together in the latent space
in a similar fashion we can say let's
take all of them use in the Sigma's that
are being produced by the encoder and
let's just plot them on a histogram so
we can see how many inputs come in have
a mu and Sigma in this range how many
inputs coming in have a mu and Sigma in
this range so we now have a nice
histogram of our latent variables and we
can now take everything from that
histogram and say okay if we have an
input that has that produces a latent
representation that is very uncommon
right so this big value big Q at the
bottom will be small if the input
representation is not that common which
means the overall weight that this input
gets is very high because you're taking
one divided by a small number so if it's
a common representation there's a very
small chance that we'll use this X again
as a training data point and pass it
through if it's an uncommon
representation there's a high chance
that we take this X and pass it back
through the network so this gives you a
way of sort of being able to up sample
data that is underrepresented but by
actually looking at the latent features
that encode it and not the basing it on
assumptions of the original data itself
in code this is again very similar and
simple you take the input means you
start grabbing the sample probabilities
for using these images and then here as
I said you generate a histogram for the
latent representations and using this
nice function at the bottom that comes
from Sify you can figure out for each of
the data points coming in which bin it
actually belongs in once you have all of
that you can smooth over your histogram
and invert this density function to
normalize so your probability is 1
divided by whatever that however large
that bin in this histogram is and you
use that probability to feed back into
your training probability of resampling
that value X so this is just an example
from the paper of if you run and use
this model the original image on the
left is a sample of the facial images
that the model would normally be trained
on and then once you run the model
through several times and you figure out
which sorts of inputs and which images
are underrepresented in a latent space
you get a lot less homogeneous
collection of images and by up sampling
these data points you get a hopefully
you get a model at the end that can
predict equally accurately across a lot
of different groups so this last one
we're going to zoom through very quickly
both because I'm running out of time and
because this one is very very conceptual
and what distributionally robust
optimization does is it essentially says
instead of looking at minimizing an
average for a certain population instead
of saying let's try to improve our model
for the empirical average and optimize
for that average average let's actually
look at what the different groups are
and minimize the loss based off of the
worst off group in this data set okay so
this is one example of how over time if
you're training a model it can get more
and more bias against a sort
minority population because your model
improves itself over time for a majority
which is typically reflective or for an
average which is typically reflective of
a majority population which means as you
improve slightly for the majority
population your model performs a lot
worse for minority populations in your
data sets and what we want to do here is
we want to actually just minimize the
loss based off of the worst off group so
this is a bunch of math you're saying
okay let's assume there to pay different
underlying groups they all make up a
certain population proportion of the
population and out of time okay all
right I'm gonna zoom through this very
quickly give me two minutes
so I I'm we're just going to look at the
minimizing it for the worst off group
which essentially says okay let's take
the underlying representation let's look
at the ball of possibilities around this
and minimize for all of that will you
end up getting is you train by not
looking at the loss and not really
looking at the examples that have low
loss and really up waiting the examples
that have high loss so if your example
has a very high loss then we're going to
update it we're going to give it a
square term and then the next time it
runs to the model it's based off of that
square term and ones that are already
pretty good we don't need to consider
anymore so this is the last model which
is saying let's actually change the way
you optimize to optimize for the worst
off group by ignoring a certain
population here and maximizing the good
for the worst off group and my last
caveat is just because an algorithm is
fair doesn't mean it's being used fairly
right just because we're making
predictions accurately across all
different populations doesn't mean that
actual algorithm is being used in a fair
manner so there are people coming up
with proposals such as model cards for
model reporting that says every
researcher that produces these models
need to specify all of these different
caveats all the metrics they use the
ethical can
iterations training data and disclosed
all of these information because only by
being transparent
can we actually ensure that these models
are used accurately I'm very sorry for
running over time but hopefully some of
that was useful thank you
[Applause]